sabemos que un elemento se define por el
número de protones que contiene por
ejemplo si buscamos el potasio en la
tabla periódica bueno aquí sólo he
puesto una parte de la tabla pero el
potasio se encuentra aquí y tiene 19
protones vamos a escribirlo así aunque
esto es un poco redundante porque
sabemos que el átomo de potasio tiene 19
protones por lo tanto si un átomo tiene
19 protones es potasio ahora también
sabemos que no todos los átomos de un
elemento tienen el mismo número de
neutrones si hablamos de un elemento x
en el que existen diferentes números de
neutrones decimos que son isótopos de
ese elemento
por ejemplo el potasio puede existir en
una forma en la que tiene exactamente 20
neutrones a eso le llamamos potasio 39 y
39 es el número de masa que es la suma
de 19 protones
protones más 20 neutrones
y este es el isótopo de potasio más
común aproximadamente el 90 y 3.3 por
ciento de potasio en la tierra
corresponde a este isótopo mientras que
algunos de los otros isótopos son como
por ejemplo bueno nuevamente tenemos
potasio pero ahora tenemos potasio 41 y
éste tiene 22 neutrones porque 22 más 19
es igual a 41 este isótopo corresponde
al 6.7 por ciento del potasio en el
planeta y después tenemos un isótopo muy
escaso que es el potasio 40 este isótopo
contiene 21 neutrones y es muy escaso
porque corresponde únicamente al 0.0 117
por ciento de todo el potasio pero
justamente es un isótopo de potasio muy
interesante porque a nosotros nos sirve
para la adaptación es decir la
determinación de la edad de las rocas
antiguas
realmente las rocas volcánicas antiguas
y como veremos determinar la edad de las
rocas volcánicas nos ayuda a determinar
la edad de otro tipo de rocas y fósiles
que pueden encontrarse entre esas rocas
volcánicas antiguas porque miren lo más
interesante sobre el potasio 40 es que
tiene una vida media de 1.25 mil
millones de años por lo que contrario al
carbono 14 se puede usar para determinar
la edad de las cosas muy muy antiguas
entonces cada 1.25 mil millones de años
vamos a escribirlo así
cada vida media que es de 1.25 mil
millones de años después de ese tiempo
el 50 por ciento de cualquier muestra se
habrá descompuesto el 11 por ciento se
habrá descompuesto en argón 40 miren
aquí tenemos el argón que tiene 18
protones entonces para pasar al argón 40
se pierde un protón pero seguimos
teniendo el mismo número de masa
entonces uno de los protones de alguna
forma se convierte en neutrón y captura
a uno de los electrones internos y luego
emite otras cosas pero bueno no veremos
la física cuántica de esto aquí lo
importante es que el 11 por ciento de
potasio 40 se convierte en argón 40 y el
89 por ciento se convierte en calcio 40
aquí podemos ver el calcio en la tabla
periódica tiene 20 protones así que esta
es una situación en la que uno de los
neutrones se transforma en protón
y esta es una situación en la que uno de
los protones se transforma en neutrón ya
nosotros lo que más nos interesa es esta
parte porque el argón como ya hemos
visto en los vídeos de química es un gas
noble no reacciona entonces cuando está
incrustado en algo que se encuentra en
estado líquido
simplemente se burbuja no se une a algo
solamente se burbuja y se libera a la
atmósfera
entonces imaginemos lo que ocurre
durante una erupción volcánica dibujaré
un volcán por aquí
supongamos que este es un volcán que en
algún momento del pasado erupción
entonces erupción y aquí tenemos la lava
y esa lava contiene una cierta cantidad
de potasio 40 e incluso ya contiene un
poco de argón 40 pero miren mientras
tenemos lava es decir mientras esto se
encuentra en estado líquido imaginemos
que aquí tenemos lava tenemos muchas
cosas y dentro de esto tenemos potasio
40 que lo pondré de color rosa
aquí tenemos potasio 40 aunque recuerden
que es un isótopo muy escaso y también
ya tenemos argón 40 entonces ya hay
argón 40 pero como el argón es un gas
noble y no se une a nada mientras que la
lava está en estado líquido
el argón burbujea hacia la superficie y
se libera a la atmósfera porque no está
unido a algo entonces lo más interesante
es cuando ocurren esas erupciones
como el argón 40 se escapa cuando la
lava se endurece y se convierte en roca
volcánica lo pondré de otro color cuando
se endurece todo el argón 40 se ha ido
ya no está presente así que solamente
nos quedamos con potasio 40 por eso el
argón 40 es muy interesante porque el
calcio 40 no necesariamente se libera
puede que aquí tengamos calcio 40 pero
todo el argón 40 si se libera con lo que
se reinicia la cantidad de argón 40
entonces después de ese evento y de que
ya no hay argón 40 cuando esto se
solidifica si nos adelantamos en el
tiempo y analizamos la muestra déjenme
copiar esto
entonces si después de mucho tiempo
analizamos la muestra y encontramos un
poco de argón 40 podemos saber qué bueno
sabemos que esta es una roca volcánica
sabemos que se formó por medio de un
evento volcánico anterior por lo tanto
sabemos que este argón 40 este argón 40
se formó por la descomposición del
potasio 40 y sabemos que se formó
después del evento volcánico porque de
haber estado presente desde antes se
habría liberado a la atmósfera cuando
todo esto era líquido por lo tanto el
único momento en el que el argón 40
puede existir adentro de la roca es
mediante la descomposición del potasio
40 en la roca sólida y podemos analizar
la relación porque sabemos que solamente
el 11 por ciento de los productos de
descomposición corresponden a argón 40
entonces por cada argón 40 debemos de
tener aproximadamente 9 calcio es 40
por cada argón 40 sabemos que
originalmente teníamos 10 potasio es 40
entonces lo que podemos hacer es
analizar la relación del número de
potasio 40 que tenemos ahora con el
número de potasio que debería de haber
basándonos en esta experiencia así
podemos datar o también dicho determinar
la edad de la roca en el siguiente vídeo
veremos el cálculo matemático para
demostrarles cómo pueden hacerlo y bueno
los eventos volcánicos no suceden todos
los días si buscamos en millones y
millones de años
en esa escala de tiempo en realidad no
ocurren con frecuencia entonces
suponiendo que acabamos en el suelo
hasta encontrar roca volcánica ok y si
seguimos cavando encontramos otra capa
de roca volcánica
aquí tenemos otra capa y supongamos que
en las dos hay una cierta cantidad de
potasio 40 pero vamos a suponer que aquí
tenemos más argón 40 y aquí tenemos un
poco menos y usando las matemáticas que
veremos en el siguiente vídeo podemos
decir que esta es la vida media y si
analizamos la relación que hay entre el
potasio 40 restante con lo que
encontramos que había antes vamos a
suponer que esta capa se solidificó
hacia aproximadamente 100 millones de
años 100 millones de años antes del
presente y encontramos que esta capa se
solidificó hace aproximadamente 150
millones de años antes del presente y
supongamos que este suelo no se ha
mezclado de hecho están bastante
separados al analizar las muestras pero
también supongamos que encontramos
algunos fósiles aquí encontramos un
fósil entonces aunque
las pruebas con carbono 14 ya no nos
sirven cuando pasamos de los 50 mil años
podemos encontrar a este fósil entre
esos dos periodos ese es un buen
indicador claro si podemos suponer que
el suelo no se ha mezclado así que este
fósil se encuentra entre los 100 y los
150 millones de años primero ocurrió
este evento después estos animales
murieron se depositaron estos fósiles y
después ocurrió este evento volcánico
así que aunque únicamente estemos
determinando la edad de la roca
volcánica podemos conocer también la
edad de lo que se encuentra entre esas
capas así que no solamente adaptamos
roca volcánica sino que también podemos
determinar la edad de otras cosas muy
muy muy antiguas y podemos llegar más
allá de lo que nos permiten llegar las
pruebas con carbono 14